[Applaudissements]
avec la nouvelle ou la prise aujourd'hui
c'est magnifique gad et kiev vont faire
un spectacle ensemble que deux
spectacles alors déjà tournée dans toute
la france en octobre novembre 2016 et
paris bercy du 23 au 27 novembre 2007
juste une question à vous poser
oui parce que les gars moi je vous le
dit j'étais content mais j'ai juste une
petite déception alors voilà c'est que
j'ai l'impression que ça c'est très beau
on voit pas longtemps mais parce que
c'est unique parce que ça c'est vraiment
parce que c'est unis parce que c'est pas
c'est pas une formation de dios est un
événement c'est chaque on le fait mais
tu vois ça un moment quoi aller très
vite les chiffres parce que là à mon
avis ça va partir de président et donc
après terminé à la vermine
si tu l'as pas même la peur 18 14
juillet tu as a vu très peu de dates
mais de dire les dates qu'on va faire on
va tout donner ah ouais ça m'échappe
tout ça je jette comme un fou faites
comme en font mais nous on est déjà
comme des fous j'me voyais déjà qu'on
était comme un après mais là qu'est ce
que je peux vous souhaitez qu'est ce que
je peux souhaiter
moi je moi je souhaite que le prochain
spectacle de lui il marche bien
[Rires]
bon franchement je vous souhaite bien
même serait ce parce qu'il est de 3
générique condensats peu avant que vous
parti veut qu'on enseigne et boon et
julie delpy qui vont arriver gré mais là
et on sait un petit débat c'est est ce
que tu veux mais au jeu direct et c'est
ce qui est énorme c'est que ma mère elle
m'a dit vas-y mais ne donnera pas soit
je le fais à fond je leur ai bien tu ne
sais pas danser sur un truc qui a déjà
démarré alors que chiant après le
comprendre geoffroy jacky 14 ou de
plaies merci qui merci jackie et michel
nature mais rien c'est moi que j'espère
que je vais faire paf et bonne musique
adacore donc tout un jeu pas le gars
c'est mia frye deux époux musique on y
va attention c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lauzière
et
[Musique]
motif
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
motors merci père ou d'abord ce n'est
pas bouclé il avait marqué avec les
musiques va de la vie aux années 80
c'est l'ipod de gad que vous écoutez moi
je suis fatigué je dois me coucher lui
je pense qu'il va rester
on y va tous les deux et on a hâte de
vous retrouver sur scène tout est
possible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]